nouvelle création originale ça les
panthères j'ai roulé tous rangés ranger
ou hagard cv et se prendre en main je
sais que j'aurai vers quelque chose
d'autre
et vous et la tâche sera beaucoup plus
simple c'est encore ça des assurances tu
connais ça il ya des gens à qui je
pourrai manquer
si les panthères sont mensah j'ai
vraiment besoin de mon experte en
diamants j'ai besoin d'elle et rock dans
mon petit frère jetage d'arranger le
groupe mais faut que tu nous parles
[ __ ] fais juste attention à ce que tu
fais où tu mets les pieds
où vont être acheminés les diamants les
panthères stienne nord
panthère nouvelle série inédite lundi 26
octobre sur canal+